[Musique]
interdire la chasse le week-end et
pendant les vacances scolaires c'est une
des promesses de campagne du candidat
écologiste yannick jadot j'interdirais
la chasse le week-end j'interdirais la
chasse pendant les vacances scolaires en
cause des accidents de chasse trop
nombreux selon lui trois quarts des
personnes qui vivent dans la ruralité
n'ose pas aller se promener le dimanche
quand il ya des tirs de fusil c'est pas
normal déclaration qui a fait monter au
créneau les amateurs de chasse et willy
schraen président de la fédération
nationale des chasseurs il anti chasse
sont les gens qui paris voilà donc si on
ne peut pas le faire pendant lui calé on
peut pas le faire pendant les vacances
au moins caniggia douai est juste de
quoi le salé au bout de ses convictions
d'après l'office français de la
biodiversité l'an dernier 140 est une
victime de la chasse et 11 morts ont été
recensés alors selon vous faut-il
interdire la chasse
merci d'être avec nous il n swi merci
d'être là vous êtes candidate
appartiennent humaniste aux élections
présidentielles merci d'être là hélène
et mathieu mathieu pallier sa soeur et
mon chat
merci alors faut-il interdire la chasse
oui gilles guillaume c'est ça un an j
laminant finalement et non je pense
comme monsieur
alors que cet achat alors juste qui est
contre qui veut interdire la chasse vous
qui m'a pas que non mais alors où il ya
des blessés cause de la chasse est alors
on veut protéger des animaux je pense
qu'il ya aucun argument pour continuer à
chasser la cdu csu été délégués qui
blesse aussi des humains oui et ce qu'il
sait que c'est une tradition ça n'a
aucun sens a plein de tradition il ya
plein de tradition débiles qu'on a fait
disparaître la société évolue c'est pas
parce que on fait quelque chose et que
quelque chose juste dure depuis des
années que ça doit continuer voilà il
est plein de tradition des bills ya 50
ans mais on voulait fumer les femmes en
simple on l'a fait arrêter ben là c'est
pareil la chasse est une pratique alors
dévoilé sur tuer on n'arrête pas la
voiture si j'ai bien alors je vous dis
neuf fois sur dix la victime est un
chasseur mais cette fois sur dix il
s'agit même d'un autopsie dont vous
confirmez mathieu ah oui ce qui est
intéressant de savoir déjà c'est qu'en
fait aujourd'hui on parle énormément
effectivement des accidents chasse parce
qu'il y en a et c'est tragique on est
bien d'accord mais en vingt ans les
accidents de chasse ont été divisées
d'enfin il ya 70 % d'accidents mortels
en moins qui a 20 ans ce qu'il faut
savoir c'est qu'on n'en parlait pas il
ya 20 ans on en parle beaucoup beaucoup
plus aujourd'hui mais en fait voilà vous
voyez la courbe effectivement qui est
descendu et on est même tombé à la
saison dernière 2020 2021 à cet accident
mortel les locaux vides alors absolument
pas de faire une idée n'est pas
absolument pas de faire une fête et
c'est tragique 1 6 7 2 3 on est bien
d'accord certes il ya eu samedi un homme
de 67 ans a dû être transporté en
urgence au chu de rennes la thèse
privilégiée un accident de chasse de
chasse le tireur présumé est un chasseur
de 70 ans qui aura atteint au cou
l'automobiliste oui la victime est en ce
moment dans un état critique on pense
fort à l on espère qu'elle va s'en
sortir en tout cas la victime n'en pense
à sa famille et jeudi c'était déjà un
accident de chasse qui aurait pu coûter
la vie à un promeneur lors d'une battue
au sanglier en haute savoie un chasseur
a tiré et blessé le promeneur qui se
trouvait sur un chemin de promenade le
jeune homme a eu le thorax perforé mais
ses jours ne sont pas en danger qu'est
ce que vous en pensez et là il vous pour
vous il faut interdire la chasse
complètement oui clairement c'est
évident qu'il faut interdire la chasse
et les propos du président de la
fédération de chasse finish règles sont
absolument sereine on va voir ce qu'il a
dit oui je serai toujours chose dont je
crois il était sur sud radio regardez
donc vous même en tant que président de
la fédération nationale des chasseurs
interdire la chasse le week-end et les
vacances scolaires c'est tout simplement
aberrant je pense que c'est complètement
débile d'ailleurs parce que si vous
l'avez cadets à quelque chose mais que
la thalie la chasse tout court parce que
vous savez les gentils chats sont les
gens qui travaillent bon en attendant on
sait que l'accident est paru et le
risque zéro n'existe pas on s'est tous
un mais gentil qui lisent des armes sont
des gens qui sont formés qui reçoivent
régulièrement des formations de sécurité
bon il ya des fois ça peut être l'erreur
humaine elle vit dans le cas de cette
excitante ghislaine pourquoi ce jour là
cette balle a ricoché à lapider
tragiquement impossible à traverser des
halles a traversé un bois et à
d'interminables voiture alors ça c'est
choquant pour ça c'est inacceptable
risque zéro il existe effectivement
parce que si on interdit la chasse mais
ya zéro risque et quand j'entends
monsieur qui nous expliquent les
accidents de chasse ont diminué bas et
pourquoi en fait la plupart des gens ont
tellement peur à la campagne de se
promener grand période de chasse qu'ils
ne sortent plus et en plus surtout les
chasseurs ont complètement diminué en
nombre il ya deux millions et demi dans
les années 70 ils sont huit cent mille
aujourd'hui 5 milliards c'est fait c'est
parce que les gens qui sont terrorisés à
la même si vous sortez d'un chiffre
laisse moi les corriger aujourd'hui un
million deux cent mille chasseurs est en
fait qu'il faut savoir c'est qu'on tire
ça va 5 fois plus de bâle qui à 20 ans
ainsi donc en fait c'est cardiaque
cherchez l'erreur non ça c'est pas vrai
il n'y a jamais eu autant d'animaux dans
les forêts actuellement
la gestion des populations aujourd'hui
est faite par louer quoique l'office
national de la biodiversité
avec les populations d'animaux par
territoire ils font des contrôles de
nuit chaque année traîné pour y assister
qui calcule les les le grandissement des
populations est établie par rapport à ça
des plans de chasse les chasseurs ne
sont pas libres de tuer tout ce qu'ils
veulent ce n'est absolument pas vrai
vous avez droit vous allez je vais
courir on chasse le droit tu es quoi
mais il ya plein d'animaux qui ont
chassé il y avait hier de ce qu'on
appelle le gros gibier c'est à dire
cerfs sangliers chevreuils va y avoir
des oiseaux va y avoir de rien alors il
ya une chose qui a chassé toutes les
semaines ou mois je passe toutes les
semaines alors moi je sais à ce
particulièrement à court donc
moi c'est une chose que j'apprécie
particulièrement
fins débattue mais un chien c'est qui ce
fait c'est la chasse qui est pour moi la
plus naturelle qui soit parce qu'on va
venir confronter animal sauvage à des
chiens les chiens qui sont des contes
ateliers la mettre en face à l'endurance
mais qui est un avantage considérable
c'est qu'on vient
stimuler un animal sauvage dans son
environnement il le connaît
le débat sur la chasse à courre
mental c'est que un animal il va être
ces chasseurs les chiens les chiens vous
avoir dix minutes un quart d'heure 20 25
minutes de retard un cerf un sanglier un
chauffeur il à prendre 25 me down sur
les chiens on va faire un parcours va
faire des ruses et nous en connaissons
nos chiens on va suivre cette piste pour
la remontée on n'est pas du tout sur une
chasse pour moi que c'est pas barbare
mais ce que l'on joue dans les règles de
l'animal sauvage il a toutes les
qualités de manager vincent qui
permettrait d'aller défendre non aimé
vous dire qu'à faire tout le temps c'est
complètement faux on est la chasse qui
prélève le moins par rapport aux gens
des choses qu'on organise trois chances
sur quatre ne prend pas on ne prend pas
moi je fais 50 chasse par an je prends
entre sept et huit animaux par an sur
cinq ans de chasse est en revanche ah
oui les animaux beaucoup moins
aujourd'hui
sur les animaux comprend effectivement
l'an dernier n'avait donc été blessées
qui avaient été blessés par des bagnoles
bas les chiens tombe dessus et le
prélèvement ça c'est la loi de la nature
mathieu la nature n'ont alors pas ce que
vous avez entendu la west on parle de
tout ça exploration pas si on parle de
tout la chasse normal moi un animal il
est dans son livre ici ses billes dans
son élément tout d'un coup ils
s'envolent qui va être tué quelques
mariages second navré savais pas je
déteste me répéter mais ça me choque
moins la chasse à courre oui ça c'est
horrible cette souffrance est déjà une
heure deux ans oui j'en ai vu et on a vu
cet hommage et la donne vous avez déjà
suivi une chasse à courre à mais jamais
j'irai messieurs c'est horrible c'est
vraiment le jeu des humains vous allez h
pas la marche était le juge si le jeu
des humains contraints à l'aps la
vanoise et or ils ont chassé à cheval on
chasse à pied c'est le lièvre l'animal
la même chose d'assez pour vous amuser
vous êtes vous atteindrez rien
animatrice pour vous amuser rien c'est
une distraction et direction ne s'est
pas créé les questions de savoir ce qui
moi me plaisait en chasse à courre je me
suis posé la question oui quel crime
mais moi ce qui m'intéresse c'est que
insert il a des qualités moi je suis
particulièrement le cerf et chasse au
cerf et le sanglier et le cerf y ait des
qualités qui sont incroyables
effectivement on peut le voir en forêt
mais quand il le ch quand on le chasse
il va avoir des russes qui sont
phénoménales qui va aller se mélanger
avec d'autres il va faire des boucs seul
et même pour en mêlée ses voix on va
observer les chiens doivent faire un jeu
que vengez pas lui un jeu que vous avez
choisi
pas du tout tu m'as tu ferais pas naître
la cour sur le sert effectivement si en
donnions la trappe nous même quand il
passe une allée ou vont le tir au monde
dépasse finalistes se serait pas
naturelle je suis d'accord mais la
chasse à courre c'est naturel qu'est ce
qu'on vient pas vraiment qu'avec la
meute qui lui qu'il est suffisant une
chance pour les conduites de gaz on en
parlait comme nouvel abattoir le voyage
de ces animaux vous vous rendez sur en
france soit une voiture de sécurité
je vois que j'ai jamais une chasse à
courre je déteste c'est de le revoir et
d'échanger c'est horrible c'est une
distraction comme ça de bourgeois le
dimanche on sait aujourd'hui avec
l'intelligence animale que l'animal
effectivement un stress qui comprend ce
qui se passe goudy c'est un jeu c'est un
jeu que j'avais choisi pas lui le cerf
il a pas du tout choisi de mourir 2 ou
de joie et vous ce jour là alors mariton
qui fait déjà de toutes les lois de la
nature en afrique au lycée palois de la
laisse du temps d'aller chasser acer du
dimanche vous parlez de pas les gentils
de chasse si un des chiens qui le chasse
c'est dans les solderies à l'école
dimanche mais les chiens qui le
chasser comprenant ya une loi qui est
passé on a arrêté c'est tout à fait
normal pourchasse pas dans les
lotissements il ya deux mois qui est
blessé mais je suis d'accord
de chiens dans un lotissement qui ont
éventré de chat donc c'est l'entrée de
chats et des chiens qui attrapent des
chats y en a partout dans toute la
journée par des émissions à cacher leur
sécurité et vous oubliez quand même la
question des élevages d'animaux parce
que ce qu'on dit pas une matière de
chasse aux intéressés qu'à 30 millions
d'amis qui sont élevées pour être
relâchés et qui sont qui servent de
cibles vivantes alors
scandale est très intéressant
aujourd'hui en france y'a pas d'élevage
de grand gibier cerf sanglier il ya
débat il
ya des élevage de sangliers pour faire
du pâté et cerner nov il ya des gars
en france maintenant sur le petit gibier
effectivement il ya une grande partie du
petit gibier qui a chassé en france 1
million d'arrivées non mais déjà vous
sortez de chez différents il ya trop les
animaux les petits gibiers sont lâchés à
trois périodes de l'année il y en a deux
que je trouve intéressante ces dépôts
des lâchers de repeuplement à la fin de
la saison de chasse ou moment de la
reproduction sur les perdrix et faisans
ça c'est intéressant pourquoi parce
qu'aujourd'hui on a une agriculture
intensive qui utilisent des produits
chimiques qui détruit ces espèces là on
a décidé de rayer les haines nos cartes
et on a fait des cultures à perte de vue
qui font qu'on ait ces animaux +3
protéger un maire est donc effectivement
ces populations de faisans de perdre et
on diminue même et de faire du gras que
battu intérêts sont maintenant moi je
suis d'accord avec vous je suis contre
totalement le lâcher la veille pour les
flinguer lendemain sache que c'est une
aberration mais je suis sûr que ça
disparaîtra dans les années à venir
parce que saddam et irréel c'est quoi le
jeune homme étudie le mathieu mathieu
c'est quoi le quine de la chasse en fait
c'est quoi le alors vous manger la
viande non non non non pas de la poésie
ravoux le dimanche devenir
meilleur marché comme actif aujourd'hui
enfoncé à 98 profond de la population
qui mangent de la viande sein du ser
aient quoi ça
c'est très bon train aujourd'hui 98 %
des gens ne mangent de la viande ils
viennent de deux sources différentes il
yad'un côté de l'élevage alors il ya
plein de types d'élevage ainsi autant de
types d'élevage que deux campagnes en
france et ils peuvent venir de la chasse
moi qui mangent de la viande je me dis
qu'elle est chassé un animal sauvage de
le tuer de le manger de cuisine et de le
manger parce que je cuisine aussi le
curé de le manger ça a du sens déjà je
me cache pas derrière un abattoir un
monde inconnu rouge me dit ah non moi je
veux pas voir l'animal un animal dans la
mort jeu juste avoir une barquette
charest devant moi où je cuisine non non
l'avantagent de la chasse et comment
vous assumer seul mathieu de kyoto
gilles monsieur m'a fait changé d'avis
parce que monsieur la manière dont vous
parlez de cette chasse de jouissance
terre que vous jouissez de la souffrance
de l'animal on peut le dire mais vaut
rien à vos mots vous prononcez le mot on
joue vous jubilez ne la souffrance bleus
et de chasse à la mecque ou d'un châle
makoun est une hérésie qui remonte à des
6es de
la loi la chasse à courre doit être
absolument interdite c'est un scandale
c'est le massacre d'animaux qui n'ont
rien demandé c'est inutile on n'est pas
du tout dans l'absence édition du buzz
jamais passionnément par une sortie
d'allemagne avec monsieur la manière
dont vous méprisez la souffrance animale
est une honte et vous me faites mal
parce que en fait déjà débat imminente
est arrêté ça rien agréable ça n'a rien
à voir peu exposés
vous le disiez l'ont entouré le sel est
dans mon dieu dans gomorra qui avait là
jouissant de faire souffrir l'animal
mais monsieur c'est dégueulasse
parce qu'il a dit non merci elle n'a pas
dit ça seulement il a dit le plaisir de
jouer avec l'animal avec le plaisir quoi
se rebeller pas les serveurs comme s'il
n'avait pas eu à se défendre alors
actuel sacrés pouvait pas laisser dire
ça que les cieux gildo minute mathieu
bernat j'ai jamais dit ça je parle pas
de jeu je parle pas de plaisir la
jouissance de dante ou un animal la
guerre je dis ça mais vous avez dit que
vous jubilez de clamer suivre sérieuses
pour faire du buzz fois on fait une
émission où effectivement on peut
échanger intelligemment sur des sujets
mais moi je suis pas en train de dire
que vous voilà vous inventez de vous
inventer des choses et en plus vous
mangez de la viande mais aller dans un
abattoir vous êtes vous l'avez déjà fait
déjà parler des abattoirs
que vous faites si vous l'aviez vous
mais moi j'en ai assez qu'on veut
toujours tout interdire après la chasse
à courre moi c'est une image mentale
cheval c'est une horreur c'est une mise
à mort inutile s'agit d'accords après la
chasse paraît-il que c'est simple mais
ça ça permet de réguler certains animaux
pourquoi pas moi j'ai horreur de la
chasse mais qu la notion d'interdît
redon se maintenant en france n'est
qu'un pâle il faut tout interdire je
suis contre ça on est d'accord bono y
voilà par contre la cour la gestuelle
avec lui tout ce qui fait souffrir les
animaux mais puisque tout ce qui est
inutile et qui avait une souffrance
animale et une balle de chasse à tir qui
sépare bat fait ça veulent pas souffert
voilà la chasse une ville trahison
français n'ont pas empêché les gens de
choisir mais un million de chasseurs
très bien mais au moins respecter
l'animal un minimum et quand vous êtes à
cheval derrière un serbe ou d'immeubles
en compte et pas n'importe quoi qui vous
fait kiffer c'est d'être à cheval d'être
comme ça tu dois tout donner
mais moi j'aimerais bien mais vous avez
fait très bien de chasser comme ça et ça
c'est une souffrance inutile parce que
les serbes ou allez vous tirer une balle
effectivement c'est plus rapide et voilà
et c'est efficace bellechasse à la glu
vous êtes pour c'est quoi la chasse à la
grenouille on
fait quoi vous savez ce qu'on en fait
des oiseaux bon ce que vous parlez de
chasser la glu vous savez ce que c'est
la finalité c'est quoi mettre les a
frappés et ensuite des bancs j'ai dit
non non c'est ça qui est intéressant
c'est que les gens qu'ils entendent être
ça lui fait mal et ça l'a vu c'est
pratiqué par une trentaine de personnes
en france d'accord c'est une tradition
ancestrale c'est des systèmes de chasse
qui existe dans les forêts amazoniennes
sur lesquels quand on regarde les
reportages des formats disponibles mais
vraiment c'est formidable pourquoi si on
voit un indien dans la forêt amazonienne
en train d'attraper un oiseau avec un
bâton 30 cm et lacolle ils se posent
dessus il attrape son oiseau toulon
trouve ça formidable halte et il fait
alors ensuite mis
le cap sur un oiseau il le récupère et
ensuite il sert d'appelants pour la
chasse à la glu mais la chasse à la
griffe qui est une chasse ne tire comme
une chasse à tir voilà un appelant donc
c'est justement un animal qu'on va
mettre dans un dans une dans une petite
cage voilà qui va servir à appeler les
autres griffes ou les fermes et hameaux
c'est ça non quand il m'a dit ça que je
crois qu'elle est bien le dicton
ce
que je vienne avec moi peut-être pas
faire un débat aujourd'hui moi je trouve
que barbara pompigne chemise de la
transition écologique a comme des sujets
un peu plus important que trente 30
personnes qui font la capture de griffes
sur des bateaux avec de la colle donc
les réponses
des choses plus importantes et ben non
mais les réponses vous avez de monsieur
de ville et sereine la fondation
caricature c'est un sketch du film 26
étaient pas source de tant de
souffrances pour les animaux autant
d'insécurité pour les gens ça serait
risible sauf que c'est pas risible il ya
constamment des accidents constamment
des violences faites aux animaux de la
cruauté et une majorité de citoyens sont
contre ces chasses et d'en face à
fédérer vendredi dernier ou dernière
c'est faux vendredi chez jean jacques
bourdin candidat écologiste yannick
jadot a demandé des réponses fermes pour
lui il faudrait interdire la chasse à
certaines périodes cela regarde
je veux qu'on sorte d'une politique sous
influence du lobby de la chasse on a
encore eu un accident un promeneur liés
en haute savoie qui a pris une balle à
côté d'un cimetière il va falloir que la
nature soit accessible à tout le monde
et je m'interdirais la chasse le
week-end j'interdirais la chasse pendant
les vacances scolaires je veux qu'on
puisse se balader dans la nature
week-end pas de chasse pendant les
vacances scolaires et évidemment on ne
chasse pas les espèces protégées et on
arrête la chasse à courre et toutes les
chasses cruel
pour qu'on arrête ce que vient de dire
yannick jadot moi je suis d'accord à
100% c'est à dire arrêter la chasse à
courre pas ce que je ressens barbare
pardonnez moi monsieur je suis
mais voilà de toute façon la chasse en
général j'ai du mal à saisir mais il y à
un million et demi de personnes qui la
pratiquent et ces gens là même si on
leur dit n'arrête had arrêtés ils
n'arrêteront pas donc il faut l'encadrer
comment on encadre c'est à dire
qu'effectivement il va falloir que la
forêt appartient à tous et pas qu'aux
chasseurs attendons en plus à leurs
maîtres fort apache termes de prix
ciblées et ce que m appartement
appartient à tous niveaux oui
c'est à dire des c
[Rires]
est avec des majors rencontre
intéressante parce que la forêt
n'appartient pas qu'aux chasseurs mais
pardon alors au parquet elle a par
ailleurs mal tout le monde la connaît
doumi powell appartient à tout le monde
sauf les propriétés privées mais vous
savez pas ce que vous savez ce que ça
représente et collecter les propriétés
privées et peu importe mais on
s'intéresse aux livres ont soufflé blake
a été muet les promeneurs mais pas au
prix a été privé c'est 80% du territoire
font très bien c'est le corps ne
semblait sur la route c'est une voie
publique et vous et non mais attendez
regarde personne qualité gsm ou récital
non mais samedi je venais sur la droite
vous dis pas les mentionner bâle-ville
aubry était privé quant à sentir et on
les plombs bah oui c'est pas bien j'en
ai d'ailleurs que les accidents je dis
juste que aujourd'hui partir du constat
que la forêt appartient à tout le monde
malheureusement c'est faux c'est 20%
aujourd'hui du territoire français qui
est effectivement qui sont effectuons
des domaines d'état dans lequel mais
alors qu'en soit tension faut faire la
différence entre des domaines publics et
des domaine privé de l'état les forêts
domaniales sondés domaine privé de
l'état vous avez un droit de passage
nous chasseurs loué le territoire ça
déjà c'est pas normal joie simple balle
pied des conventions de locarno metal ou
payantes c'est non mais c'est pas eu
qu'une seule annulation de la forêt
attendait c'est une équipe ayant pour
l'entretien de la forêt oui mais
la forêt elle non mais on marche sur la
tête vous êtes en train de dire que
c'est pas normal que nous on paye j'ai
choisi c'est parce qu'ils en ont plein
le playbook et bonjour equity et des
jours encadré et mes talents jours
témoignent elles ne sont pas chauds
c'est le dimanche ses opérations il alla
s'est alors si j'appelais mon nom s'il
vous plaît sur la chasse on
dit tout à l'heure je vous a parlé d'une
certaine jouissance à tuer les animaux
et vous étiez canal mais le problème
c'est que sexy mme c'est pas un travail
c'est une activité qui vous fait plaisir
mesure est la finalité c'est un animal
non vous mentez
ça court il n'y a aucun désir la
finalité ce n'est que de manger non
c'est travail des chiens
jim à quoi on a quand même je vous dis
on a un élevage de centaines de chiens
non alors on sent des chiens 365 jours
par an d'accord un élevage ils ont des
prêts déjà ce qui est quand même bien
c'est que sont les chiens qui vivent en
famille le chien n'est jamais été
solitaire les chiens dépens de tout à
l'heure vous chasser ben vous nourrir
matin vous cherchez pas plus à la
rochelle non attendez je vous parle de
la chasse dans la globalité il avons
parlé de chasse à courre pas de la
chasse à courre non mais c'est différent
la sarthe d'achat de la chasse à courre
on ne prend pas assez pour que tout le
monde se nourrissent qu'on est d'accord
maintenant toutes les parties
comestibles de l'animal sont mangés par
les humains et le reste est donné à
manger aux chiens le effectivement nous
il ya aujourd'hui 45 espèces de chiens
qui n'existe que parce qu'elle chasse à
courre qu'elle chasse mais mon général
c'est à dire que ces espèces qui
disparaîtrait moi je suis passionné
section par les chiens je suis
passionnée par les chevaux moi j'ai mon
cheval j'ai récupéré dans l'abattoir
pour tout vous dire parce qu'aujourd'hui
on a trois mille chaud aux parents qui
sont récupérés des abattoirs par les
chasseurs mais vous savez il ya des
réglages des big france ils vont très
bien mais ça m'était chasseurs et c'est
incroyable
déjà c'est une réalité moi je d'acheter
à l'abattoir j'ai vécu par l'abattoir
j'ai passé quinze ans avec lui on hache
à son ensemble c'était voilà glg je suis
un cheval aux exceptionnels voilà je
suis passionné chevaux je suis passionné
de chien et ce travail des chiens et
passionnant parce que quand on
s'intéresse aux animaux moi depuis tout
petit champ vers les reportages
animaliers je suis passionné par sa
quand on voit des bushmen chasse à
l'endurance dans le kalahari qu'un
désert du nord de la frontière sud qui
chassa l'endurance je trouve ça
exceptionnel je vous sauvez un cheval en
tuant un animal
et sachets mathieu darche est une chose
qui est intéressante c'est que il ya des
quotas de serre ouais si les pattes je
suis à cours il sera tué attire c'est
tout calé
et c'est parce que les chiens qui croise
mis à l'essai le prenne c'est bon c'est
bon mathieu bâtir ils le font pas
mathieu qu'elle y tenait il est vrai qu
il y a beaucoup de chasseurs on peut
dire contemplateur de la nature il aime
se balader il aime observer le plus fort
oui je sais je sais la plupart et c'est
pour ça que c'est malheureux que la
finalité ce soit la mort pourquoi vous
ne prenez pas vos chiens vous allez leur
faire plaisir vous allez sauver vos
chiens comme je le dit et vous aller
contempler la nature entre amis
pour moi ce qui serait plus intéressant
de mon
nom mais la plus basse qu'il aimerait ce
dont je rêve je vais vous dire son
balcon déjà on diminue drastiquement
notre quantité de viande qu'on mange
parce que écologiquement c'est pas
possible et c'est pas tenable et bien
d'accord que la plupart de la viande
qu'on mange et viennent de chasse parce
que le gibier sont des amis
s'en vont vous dire la vérité quand je
t'ai
ya une adrénaline pour vous aider ta
vérité quand même bien rire et plaisir
mais on a su humain s'est construit là
dessus
l'être humain c'est qu'on fait
heureusement qu'il y en a qui ont chassé
pour être là où on est aujourd'hui et
j'aimerais moi que la viande qui je dis
parce que ce sont des animaux sauvages
au niveau du bien-être animal mais il
n'y a rien à lessay manche et les bars
sauvage courait sous les
allez on va voir ce qu'on pensait oui 57
pendant ces maïs ou la toussaint quand
on fait soit 168 % oui 43% peu importe
en réalité c'est bien moins que ça c'est
dans ce qu'ils disent oui il n'ya pas
beaucoup finalement